did you guys play Powerball I meant to
yeah did you really yeah yeah you did
you did Gail okay all right well I guess
luck eluded you
and he didn't make it and everybody else
and everybody else because there was no
Grand Prize winner last night after the
drawing uh the prize for Saturday's
drawing has now grown to an estimated
one and a half billion dollars that
would be just short of the world record
of nearly 1.6 billion dollars a
Powerball jackpot shared by three
winners in 2016. the grand prize could
even grow larger if people buy enough
tickets before the drawing it's like
just go out and spend more and you know
here's a math quiz for people and I
think I'm right about this okay so
yesterday's drawing the chances of
winning was one in 292 million yeah if
you play again today what are your
chances of winning one in 292 million
thank you black
yeah people think if you play
consecutively it somehow changes the
odds no the odds are the odds
don't change
well done and I'm still gonna get it
right I might actually have to play I'm
gonna have to play today I I know it
doesn't I know that it's a foolish game
I get it I get it but I like it it's fun
it's fun I like dreaming fun dreaming
and I want to play because you're going
to want to know why when I give you my
talk of the table that's why I'm gonna
play today okay as a little tie to our
talk of the tank